some things should be censored
and one of those things that should be
censored
is an adidas ad that came out yesterday
took over the internet got everyone
talking about it which i guess was the
point i'm talking about it we're all
talking about it
it was an ad that just showed
lots and lots
of boobs so i saw this saw this going
around
they said oh adidas is just showing a
lot of breasts dozens of breasts in
their ad and i
i did not
search for it i did not look at the ad
because i thought
look if i look at this this could be an
occasion of sin
right if i'm going to look at this ad
that i'm being told is just a bunch of
boobs then that might arouse
impure thoughts in my mind that i might
willfully be enter i don't want to do
that okay that would be i don't want an
occasion of sin because i i looked at
this adidas ad but then look i had to
cover it everyone was talking about it
so i said okay i'll look at it very
quickly
i am
happy
maybe i'm maybe happy to report
the ad is not an occasion of sin
because the
the picture the pictures don't look
great okay i don't i don't want to be
offensive to the models and it's not
they didn't
the the
the modeling community is not sending
their best the adidas ad
was physically about as unattractive as
an ad could be adidas the sneaker
company
and i guess they i assume they make bras
or sports bras or say otherwise this ad
would make no sense they are now
advertising their product by
by publishing
intentionally ugly looking
boobs
uncensored you know free the nipple just
totally
out there
on the one hand what's good is that it's
not i don't think it's going to arouse
lustful thoughts in anybody either
not that it's not i don't think so i
would bet i would bet a lot of money on
that but on the downside it is
participating in something
that i'm noticing pretty much every
company participating in now
which is
a
fascination with
ugly things
i'm not even i'm not saying these women
are ugly even but the photos are
intentionally trying to make them look
as ugly as they can
they're not in in the old days
back when i was a young whippersnapper
growing up
models were really really hot you look
around at billboards and it was the
hottest women you could possibly see in
magazines in all advertisements
in fact editors would go in and take
already extremely beautiful women
and then try to touch them up and
airbrush and do this and that to make
them look even more beautiful
companies sold their products by
associating the products with beauty
now
it's almost always the opposite they're
always trying to associate their
products with ugliness
with deformities
with grotesque images with obscenity
with it's a it's a cult of ugliness
it's i guess a
uh
an analogy here would be how
in in the olden days when we studied
history we would try to or literature
for that matter so much of education
would be focused on beautiful things
right you would focus on good things
not to the entire exclusion of bad
things and ugly things but you would you
would focus on good things and on beauty
now it's always the opposite all you
ever focus on in history are the sins
and the imperfections and the failures
all you ever focus on in literature is
ugliness and fallenness and anti-heroes
that's all you're getting in the culture
there's no it's all just
it's all just yuck
that's all we're getting
this is a big problem in our you know it
was one of the best things donald trump
did in his presidency
though it probably won't have much of an
effect he signed an executive order
saying that we need to make federal
buildings beautiful again
the federal buildings in washington dc
for much of our nation's history were
really beautiful and they were built in
a beautiful style of architecture and
they were big and grand and
awe-inspiring and now they're ugly
they're just gross they're brutalist and
they're intentionally incongruous and
they're just ugly and they make you feel
small
in new york in the old penn station you
would walk in you'd feel like a king it
was huge it was beautiful it was in
these beauties beautiful bozar style
then they knocked it down
and and built up madison square garden
and the new penn station makes you feel
like a little rat it makes you feel
small and dirt and you don't it's not
good it's not good when you have a
society living in ugliness all the time
did you know that one out of three
americans regularly suffer from nausea
we have all experienced that horrible
feeling whether it's in the backseat of
a car staring at your phone
after uh one too many coca-colas on a
night out with friends or even just the
anxiety of a work day you've got to
check out relief band it's the number
one fda cleared anti-nausea wristband
that has been clinically proven to
quickly relieve and effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness chemotherapy
and a lot more the technology was
originally developed over 20 years ago
in hospitals to relieve nausea from
patients now through a relief band it's
available to everyone the product is 100
drug-free non-drowsy provides
all-natural long-lasting relief with
zero side effects for as long as needed
they just released their newest model
relief band sport the sport is
waterproof has an extended battery life
can even attach to your apple or android
watch go get it right now
they make a great gift any time of year
getting an exclusive offer just for our
listeners if you go to reliefband.com
use promo code knulls get 20 off plus
free shipping and no questions asked 30
day money back guarantee best offer
you'll find for relief band anywhere got
to use my code
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d dot com promo code
knolls for 20 off plus free shipping
glad you like that clip
ring the bell please
ring the bell
subscribe get notifications head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe there to the michael knowles
show leave a five star review we
probably just put up ten you know leave
two five star reviews if you can i don't
know i don't really know how it works
subscribe we will see you next time
[Music]